foreign
[Music]
books today I am finally able to show
you intol's long-awaited arc graphics
cards feels like we've been talking
about these upcoming Intel gpus for
years now
and maybe we have been a little over a
year ago now Tim covered Intel's
architecture Day 2021 where Intel
detailed their Arc Alchemist gpus along
with xcss AI based upscaling this was
incredibly exciting stuff at the time
due to an industry-wide shortage of
graphics cards thanks to Mining and back
then people were spending big money on
old outdated second-hand graphics cards
so a new product from Intel would have
been very welcomed sadly though Intel
missed that incredible window of
opportunity by about a year as today
marks the introduction of the arc a750
and a770 graphics cards
yeah there are two versions of the a770
the standard 8 gigabyte model and then a
more premium 16 gigabyte model Which
Intel calls The Limited Edition version
but it's no way limited so not sure
about that anyway the a770 limited
edition that we have on hand for testing
comes in at an MSRP of 350 while the
standard 8 gigabyte model costs three
hundred and thirty dollars then there's
the slightly cut down a750 which costs
290 dollars
the a770 features 32 XE cores 32 Ray
tracing units and operating frequency of
2.1 gigahertz and a 225 watt power
rating
now the 16 gigabyte version enjoys a
memory bandwidth of up to 560 gigabytes
per second while the cheaper 8 gigabyte
version not only has half as much vram
but the bandwidth has also been cut down
by nine percent opposed to 17 and a half
gigabits per second gddr6 memory on the
16 gigabyte model as it uses 16 gigabits
per second gddr6 memory opposed to 17.5
gigabits per second gddr6
then we have the a750 which when
compared to the a770 has 13 fewer cores
and Road tracing units at 28. 50
megahertz shaved off the operating
frequency and then the same 8 gigabytes
of vram as the 8 gigabyte version the
a770 with the same 512 gigabytes per
second memory bandwidth and a total
board power rating of 225 Watts
I should also note that all models
feature a 256-bit wide memory bus PCI
Express 4.0 times 16 support and require
an 8 Pin plus a 6 pin power input so
those are the key specifications and for
this review I'll be using the Intel
reference cards for both the a770 and
a750 and I'll check out some stuff like
cooling performance a little bit later
on
Intel's Arc Alchemist gpus also offer a
number of Hardware accelerated media
features covering media trans code
hyperin code Hardware accelerated av1
encode and air acceleration delivered by
Intel xmx however we don't normally
cover productivity performance or
encoding slash decoding benchmarks in
our gaming Focus reviews and this review
will be no exception but apart from the
fact that we don't normally cover this
stuff we're extremely pressed for time
right now coming off the back of these
N4 testing with much more to do there
and of course next week we have the RTX
I also might be testing Intel's xcess
technology but this is a feature we do
plan to cover in great detail soon
similar to the situation we saw at dlss
these upscaling Technologies require a
great deal of scrutiny and Tim will do
just that in a separate content piece
soon so make sure you subscribe for that
now for testing all gpus have been
tested at the official clock
specifications so no Factory
overclocking here the CPU used is the
ryzen 7 5800x3d with 32 gigabytes of
dual rank dual Channel ddr4 3200cl14
memory on the Asus Rog Crosshair 8
extreme motherboard and in total I've
tested 12 games at 1080P and 1440p so
let's go over the data
first up we have Rainbow Six extraction
this was the only game to have an issue
in my testing the game didn't crash but
the menus had a strange artifacting bug
Which Intel says they're aware of and it
will be fixed in a future driver update
so perhaps a non-issue moving forward
the game itself appeared to play well
and performance overall was excellent at
1080p the a750 was faster than both the
6650 and RTX 3060 while the a770 was 14
faster than the 6650 XT so that's an
impressive result and a good win for
Intel quite incredibly that margin blows
out to 24 at 1440p is the a770 managed
117 FPS and the a750 108 FPS in fact the
a770 wasn't that much slower than the
6700 XT so very impressive stuff here
indeed
the F1 2021 results were also very
impressive here the a770 was 15 faster
than the 6650 XT at 1080P and just 10
slower than the 6700 XC it also blew the
RTX 3060 out of the water to come in
just nine percent slower than the 3060
TI and the a750 also did really well
just edging out the 6650 XT and RTX 3060
jumping up to 1440p so the a770 lead the
6650 XT by a massive 21 margin pumping
at 76 fps to just 63 FPS for the Radeon
GPU and that's with Ray tracing enabled
the a750 was also strong here beating
the RTX 3060 by a 9 margin so another
very solid result here for Intel
unfortunately though things do go a bit
skew with for The Arc gpus in Horizon
zero Dawn at 1080p the a770 came in
behind even the RX 6600 making it 19
slower than the 6650 XT and eight
percent slower than the RTX 3060 so
given what we've seen so far that is a
very disappointing result
increasing the resolution to 1440p does
help out a bit and now the a770 can be
seen basically matching the RTX 3060 but
it's still eight percent slower than the
6650 XT meanwhile the a750 is only
delivering 6600 light performance so not
a good title for Arc
it's a similar story in watchdog's
Legion though performance is very good
compared to Nvidia but less impressive
compared to AMD the a770 for example was
13 faster than the RTX 3060 but a
massive 16 slower than the 6650 XT
basically the a750 was only able to
match the cheaper RX 6600 so that's a
pretty brutal outcome for Intel
however increasing the resolution to
1440p drastically changes the picture
here and now the a770 is actually able
to match the 6650 XT with 76 FPS on
average the a750 also jumped up to the
6600 XT with 70 FPS and both gpus were
much faster than the RTX 3060 so it
would seem that these Arc gpus do prefer
the 1440p resolution opposed to 1080p at
least from a competitive standpoint
shadow of the turmeric is an older
DirectX 12 title and it's not one that
Arc is well optimized for falling short
of 100 FPS on average at 1080p with just
92 FPS the a770 was only able to match
the RX 6600 making it 18 slower than the
6650 X10 10 slower than the RTX 3060.
once again though those margins do close
up at 1440p and now the a770 was just
seven percent slower than the 6650 XT
while the a750 was eight percent faster
than the RX 6600
moving on we see that Hitman 3 is a
brutal title for the arc gpus at 1080p
as here both were quite a bit slower
than the RTX 3060 a mile slower than the
6650 XT again though 1440p does help
improve the a770 and a750 standings
pushing both ahead of the RX 6600 now
the a770 was 10 slower than the 6650 XT
so still quite a bad outcome given the
price but much better than the situation
seen at 1080p
Far Cry 6 is really another poor title
for the arc gpus depending on what you
compare them to and you can see why
Intel went with the RTX 3060 because
here the a770 was just three percent
slower but when compared to the 6650 XT
it was a whopping 25 slower and 12
slower than the much cheaper RX 6600
upping the resolution of 1440p did get
the a770 alongside the RX 6600 but still
it was 18 slower than the 6650 XT so not
a good result relative to the Radeon
gpus
next we have cyberpunk 2077 and again
the 1080p results aren't pretty with the
a770 coming in behind the RX 6600 to
make it 20 slower than the 6650 XT oddly
both the a717 a750 delivered virtually
the same performance here so it does
appear to be some kind of bottleneck
either caused by The Alchemist
architecture or perhaps it's just a
driver issue it's an odd one though
because increasing the resolution to
1440p only reduced performance of the
a770 by 15
meanwhile the 6650 XT saw a more typical
42 drop and the RTX 3060 a 40 drop the
good news being that at 1440p both the
a717 a750 were faster than the 6650 XT
and in fact work much slower than the
RTX 3060 ti so that's a tremendous
result and very surprising given What
was seen at 1080p
the Dying Light 2 results are much more
competitive at 1080p the a770 edged out
the 6650xt to deliver 3060 TI light
performance and the a750 also managed to
match the 6650 XT and crushed the RTX
3060 then at 1440p the arc gpus look
very impressive and the a770 isn't that
far off the RTX 3070 all said and done
it was 16 fast and the 6650 XT while the
a750 was seven percent faster so
certainly impressive stuff here
moving on to Halo infinite The Arc gpus
can again be found delivering pretty
sub-optimal performance at 1080p as both
were slow on the RX 6600 and just 16
faster than the RTX 3050 and while I
know 16 is quite a sizeable margin When
comparing any GPU with the RTX 3050 16
is not really a sizeable margin
sadly even at 1440p the arc gpus are
massively underwhelming Halo infinite
trailing not just the RTX 3060 but also
the 6650 XT and by quite some margin as
well
now if you recall when I first
benchmarked Spider-Man remastered with a
boatload of gpus I did include the A380
and the results were pretty horrible in
fact they were very horrible shortly
after that video Intel addressed their
performance issues with a new driver but
I wasn't going to revisit that content
just for the A380 anyway performance
with the current driver is mighty
impressive as we see here with the a77
and a750 both of which crushed the RTX
3060 and 6650 XT at 1080p
the 1440p data was also very impressive
here the a770 was just seven percent
slower than the 3060 TI and almost 30
faster than the 6650 XT so amazing
performance here I just wish we saw more
of it
and here's the most disappointing result
and one of the biggest issues with The
Arc Alchemist architecture support for
older games Counter-Strike Global
Offensive might be super old and it
might only use DirectX 9 but it's by Far
and Away the most played game on Steam
with peaks of a million players daily so
more than twice that of Apex Legends for
example
and that's a huge problem for Intel
because as you can see here the
performance is nowhere with the a770 and
a750 and in case you're wondering yeah
these results are accurate and even at
1440 pits still a complete mess the game
is technically very playable but
certainly not in a competitive setting
and you'd obviously just buy a GeForce
or Radeon GPU if you played CS go or
other old games
and the power consumption is really not
anything you get excited about either
but it's far from a disaster you're
looking at similar power usage to that
of the much faster rated RX 6800 for the
a770 as it bumped up consumption by 23
over the 6650 XT the a750 was really no
better so in terms of power efficiency
and performance per watt Arc is kinda
bad but it's certainly not a deal
breaker
okay time for cooling performance and
I'm just going to skim over this section
the Intel reference cards worked well
they certainly look simple but nice
enough and the build quality is good
though they are a bit of a pain to take
apart anyway the a750 ran at a core
temperature of 67 degrees with the
memory at 70 degrees so both are very
acceptable especially given the 1500 RPM
fan speed which resulted in near silent
operation as you can see the GPU clocked
at 2.4 gigahertz and the memory ran at
the advertised 16 gigabits per second
then we have the a770 which run its
cores and memory at 70 degrees with a
fan speed of 1600 RPM so again it was
very quiet given the GPU is sucking down
just 155 Watts on average it's really
not that hard to cool especially by
today's standards
now looking at the 12 game average it's
pretty hard to get excited about these
new Intel art graphics cards the a770
only managed to match the RX 6600 with
102 FPS on average while the a750 was a
whisker slower with 97 FPS
the 1440p results are more compelling
but even so the a770 falling behind the
6650 XT is a rough deal from Intel and
although it looks good sitting next to
the RTX 3060 the GeForce GPU really was
already a terrible deal next to the 6650
XT so really AMD has made life difficult
here for Intel
and there's really no better way to
illustrate that point than to look at a
simple cost per frame graph and we'll
start with the 1080p data in terms of
price to Performance the a750 is only
able to match the 6600 XT while the a770
does beat out the already bad value RTX
3060 and 3060 TI but can only match the
RX 6800 which is 60 faster
really both should be compared to the
6650 XT and when doing so you learn that
the a750 costs 15 more per frame and the
a770 well it's 37 more costly per frame
yeah anyway 1440p and here things look a
lot better for Intel But ultimately
really still not good enough the 6650xt
Matched the cost per frame of the RX
6600 and that meant the a750 was three
percent more costly per frame and the
a770 21 more costly even the 8 gigabyte
version of the a770 will come out more
expensive per frame than the a750 so in
short Intel can't match the 6650 XT at
the current msrps there's really not
much more to say the cost per frame
graph really nailed it like now the a770
to the point where it really is quite
sadly Dead on Arrival that seems a bit
harsh to say as in quite a few of the
instances the performance was really
quite impressive given the price
but sadly there were a number of
instances where it was anywhere from
underwhelming to downright terrible at
the end of the day you can't even begin
to entertain the idea of paying a
premium for the a770 or a750 over
established Radeon gpus look if the RTX
3060 was as good as it gotten the sub
400 US market then the a770 or a750
might be worth a shot but unfortunately
for Intel AMD has managed to undercut in
video by quite a substantial margin
making the GeForce gpus largely
Irrelevant in the sub 400 Market
and out of Interest we asked on Twitter
how much cheaper these Arc gpus would
need to be in order for you to purchase
one over an AMD or Nvidia graphics card
the general consensus was that Intel
needed to come in at least 20 cheaper so
with the 6650 XT easily available for
300 us that means the a770 would have to
cost no more than 240 U.S for the
majority of you to go for it and that's
a discount of a little over 30 percent
so that's probably never going to happen
as Intel would likely be selling them at
a significant loss
unfortunately for Intel though that is
the reality of the situation the a770
needs to cost 240 and the a750 220
anything more than that and you might as
well buy from the established brands
and granted we're yet to properly
investigate stuff like xcss but of
course Nvidia has dlss and AMD offers
FSR so there's no chance Intel's
upscaling technology makes the arc gpus
a must-have item I also haven't really
had a time to check out the ray tracing
performance beyond what we saw in F1
2021 and that's certainly something to
explore with future content that said I
strongly believe for the most part Ray
tracing at this performance tier is
largely irrelevant as you have to
compromise too heavily on other visual
quality settings in order to achieve a
60 FPS minimum at low resolution such as
1080P and I have the same opinion of the
6650 XT and RTX 3060. overall the a770
and a750 genuinely impressed me on
numerous occasions during my testing and
there's certainly real potential for
Intel to become a genuine third
competitor in the GPU space it's just
not going to happen with Alchemist and
realistically that was never going to be
possible so unless Intel Canon is
willing to slash prices I can't
recommend you take the Gamble on either
the a770 or a750
you really are just better off buying
the 6650 XT that's simply all there is
to it so with that I'm going to end the
video here if you liked it you know what
to do subscribe also we have float plan
and patreon if you'd like more Hardware
unboxed goodness you can get stuff like
well access to our exclusive Discord
server to myself to a live stream which
I guess is also exclusive a lot of
exclusive stuff over there uh q and A's
behind the scenes content a lot of cool
stuff so if you're interested check it
out but if not that is perfectly fine
and I would like to thank you for
watching this video I'm your host Dave
and I'll see you again next time
[Music]
thank you